before we go in-depth on meiosis I want
to do a very high level overview
comparing mitosis to meiosis so in
mitosis and this is all a review if
you've watched the mitosis video in
mitosis we start with a cell we start
with a cell that has a diploid number of
chromosomes I'll just write 2n to show
it has the diploid number for human
beings this would be 46 chromosomes 46
for for 46 for humans you get 23
chromosomes from your mother 23
chromosomes from your father
or you could say you have 23 homologous
pairs which leads to 46 chromosomes now
after the process of mitosis happens and
you have your cytokinesis and all the
rest you end up with two cells that each
have the same genetic information is the
original so you now have two cells that
each have the diploid number of
chromosomes so 2n + 2 n and now each of
these cells are just like this cell was
it can go through it can go through
interphase again and it grows and it can
it can it can replicate its DNA and it's
centrosomes and grow some more and then
each of these can go through mitosis
again and this is actually how you're
most of the cells in your body grow this
is how you turn from a single cell
organism into you or for the most part
into you so that is mitosis and one way
to think when it's a cycle after each of
these things go through mitosis they can
then go through they can then go through
the entire cell cycle again and let me
write this a little bit neater mitosis
that s was a little bit hard to read now
what happens in meiosis and what happens
in meiosis I'll do that over here and
meiosis something slightly different
happens and it happens in two phases so
you will start with a you still start
with a with a cell that has a diploid
number of chromosomes so you will start
with a cell that has a diploid number of
chromosomes and in its interphase it
also replicates its DNA
and then it goes through something
called meiosis one and in meiosis one
what you end up with this two cells that
now have a haploid number of chromosomes
so you end up with two cells you now
have two cells that each have a haploid
number of chromosomes so you have N and
you have n so if we're talking about
human beings you have 46 chromosomes
here and now you have 23 chromosomes and
this in this nucleus and now you have 23
in this nucleus but you're still not
done then each of these will then go
through a phase which which I'll talk
about in a second which is very similar
to mitosis which will which will
duplicate this entire cell into two so
actually let me do it like this so now
this one you're going to have four
you're going to have four cells that
each have the haploid number that each
have the haploid number of chromosomes
and they all don't necessarily have the
same genetic information anymore because
as we go through this first phase right
over here of meiosis and this first
phase where you go from diploid to
haploid
right over here this is called meiosis 1
meiosis 1 you're essentially splitting
the homologous pairs and and so this one
might get some of the homologous some of
the some of the ones that you originally
got from your father and some of the
ones that you originally got from your
mother some of the ones you originally
got from your father some of the ones
that you originally got from your mother
they split randomly but each homologous
pairs each homologous pair gets split up
and then in this phase meiosis 2 so this
phase right over here is called meiosis
2 it's very similar to mitosis except
you're now dealing with cells that start
off with the haploid number it's
important realize meiosis is not a cycle
these cells that you have over here
these are gametes these are sex cells
these are gametes these can now be used
in fertilization if we're talking about
if you're male this is happening in your
testes and these are going to be sperm
cells if the if you are female this is
happening in your ovary
and these are going to be egg cells if
you are a tree this could be pollen or
it could be an ovule so these are but
these are used for fertilization these
will fuse together in sexual
reproduction to to get to a fertilized
egg so that which then can undergo
mitosis to create an entirely new
organism so not a cycle here although I
guess wants you know these these will
find sex cells from another organism and
and and fuse with them and then those
can turn into another organism and I
guess the whole circle of life starts
again but it's not the case with mitosis
where this could just keep on going and
going going the this cell is just like
this cell while these sex cells are
different than this one right over here
now where does this happen in the body
and we've talked about this in previous
videos these are these are the bulk of
these are your somatic cells right over
here these are the ones that make up the
bulk of your body somatic cells and
where is this happening well this is
happening in germ cells as we mentioned
if you're male it's in your testes and
if you're female it's in your ovaries
and germ cells actually can undergo
mitosis to produce other germ cells that
have a diploid number of chromosomes or
they can undergo meiosis in order to
produce sperm or egg cells in order to
produce gametes